I'm sitting here with one of the coolest
dudes I've ever met Harrison Barnes an
incredible basketball player 21 years
old playing for the Golden State
Warriors is that right that's correct I
got all that right and he played for the
University of North Carolina mmm
bless your back that's going through I
mean yeah you said be more relaxed like
you know more like a like a like a
slashing it's just yeah good yeah yeah
oh yeah we go dead fish no wonder he got
them clam hands you go Pete's here watch
out for the clam hands a big meeting guy
are you really yeah you know me my
friends you know watch your show you do
not I swear I've shown among other shows
come on and why I gotta ask you know in
relation to John Holmes got a big ol my
father and my brother named John really
related to him I am related to John home
not not the 70s porno one yeah kind of
kicks you around the court
yeah prefer yeah just some some adidas
what you wearing now well right now just
some some foreign guys she won't on some
foreign me I made you those shoes he did
well he shows that good luck hasn't let
my shoe it's the Luton well he's from
Italy not Germany oh there you go that's
the accents I've seen you don't real
hard in a dude's face and they fall over
yeah do you feel bad doing them
sometimes I feel bad for
okay that's like a Vegas thing it's a
blow to the ego man yeah
the guy has to like any scooches back he
falls on his butt and then he does the
Hulu and he slides and then you're up
there I mean I've been there before I've
been on the other side too well that's
why it feels bad cuz you know exactly
how that guy feels you get dog thing
kind of look around you know yeah
blowing on your head you know trying to
wipe your feet and trying to get loose
try to act like just keep dumb what was
I what was I knew it what was I doing
that
Oh next play oh we're running the other
way down the court oh you guys have
those big steam things where your heads
just coming out here like ah coach your
nicknames Black Falcon that's kind of
scary though
one Black Falcon here let me let me run
a scenario you're opening a door to a
porch right there yep hey don't go out
there there's a Black Falcon
ah see screaming thank you didn't imp
know I mean there could be other scarier
things what about John Holmes out there
whoa
well unless you're into it what it what
would money omission duh you said like I
like sleeping so iguanas are always
under stones just kind of taking it easy
total slob sloth but slots would be good
you put a sloth up on a basketball hoop
he'll stay up there cherry-pick all day
it's under your pillow
yeah but that's why you have a kangaroo
on Poteet yeah what happened to the
funny dung come again it used to be like
funny dunks like Dee Brown remember II
did the no-look oh yeah nobody has funny
you should do a funny dunk
I should people love Schwarzenegger
noises so just dunk and when you're like
in the air just go I
I mean even if you miss people be like
that was great
I'll get my body will you show me a
Schwartz yo yo
just move your mouth I'll do it for you
I should avoid I sometimes do this was
awesome man I wish you a best of luck in
all the events that you're doing and
thanks for taking the time and you one
smooth operator don't look
appreciate a minute dead